Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we are doing
the next part of our limitless
global reach with BGP course.
That means that we are gonna be continuing
to experiment on the Equinix metal platform,
leveraging their network and BGP support in order
to build out some sample applications that are
globally available with minimal latency.
If you don't understand what that means, then
I recommend that you go back and check
part one where I was joined by Jeremy
Tanner slash Penguin on the Internet,
where we talked about what BGP is, how
it works, and why it's important to build
low latency
globally distributed applications.
Today, we're gonna build on top of the
work that we did in the first part,
and we'll be repeating some of the first
part as well. So you don't have to
go back and watch the first part right
now. I will cover the
essentials as we go because we still need
to spin up some more Equinix ML devices,
enable BGP
and deploy a workload.
What we're gonna be doing today with that
workload is running core DNS
as a DNS server in three metros or
regions, facilities, whatever you wish to call them
around the world.
We will be using The US, Europe, and
Asia, for example.
Using BGP, we can broadcast that DNS server
with a single IP address,
which will be available to anyone
via their closest
region.
This is really cool because it means you
can build at the edge platforms. So I'm
only using three
metros
today. However, there could be as many as
you need to handle
your customers
and keep them happy at the same time.
Now, before we dive into the
hands on component of which all these courses
are,
If you wanna work along and do this
on your own, there's a link below, rawkode.linkmetal.
This will take you to the Equinix Medal
homepage,
where you can sign up and use the
code, Rawkode.
This code will get you a 200 USD
in credit to experiment and play with Equinix
Medal throughout this course.
200 USD
is around
anywhere from one hundred to four hundred hours,
depending on what size of hardware you use
on your platform.
So there is plenty,
plenty of credits there for you to experiment,
have some fun and learn some cool stuff
along the way.
That being said, we're gonna dive straight over
to my screen share.
So
this course is available and really a smarter
person would have had the link available.
Where's my mouse?
There we go.
Can't even frame my mouse, so it's a
perfect start. So let's pull this window into
display.
We have the GitHub Academy,
the Rawkode Academy GitHub page
available at github.com/rawkodeacademy.
There is a repository there called courses.
You will find the global reach BGP directory
here. This is today's session
with the README and some Pulumi automation that
we'll be taking a look at
and
pretty much everything you need to do this
on your own. However, I'm going to run
through it too. So any hiccups that I
get also means that you can see how
I fix it and I get to update
the course material,
win win.
If you have any questions throughout today's session,
please feel free to drop them straight into
the comments, or if you just wanna say
hello, go for it. I'd love to say
hello.
Alright.
So
the start of this workshop
is gonna feel very similar to part one
and that we are going to need to
provision some Equinix metal devices.
Oh, we have our first hello.
Hey, Maz. Thanks for joining us. Alright.
So
we're gonna spin off some Equinix Mail devices.
We're going to configure BGP, and we're going
to do this all manually,
run and install core DNS. Of course, I
do have the Pulumi automation here, so we'll
spin that up too, so you can see
what this would look like in a fully
automated environment.
Oh, we got a few more hellos.
Hey, Rio, thank you for joining us.
And Manuel,
thank you for saying hello. I appreciate that.
Okay. So let's get started. Today, we're gonna
spin up the core DNS and three metros.
We're gonna see how this works and then
we're gonna take a look at some automation
to do it. Now, all of this takes
a little bit of time. We have to
provision some machines and we have to automate
the provision of some machines.
They all take about ten minutes. I'm gonna
kick it all off at the start and
then we will run through the rest of
today's examples and materials.
But the first thing we need to do
here is to go to the Equinix Medal
console,
first request a global IP that we can
use as our BGP advertisement around the world.
This will be advertised on all of Equinix
Medal's autonomous systems around the Internet. If you're
not familiar, Equinix has a
completely amazing backbone around the Internet. So it's
a fantastic network to build on, and in
fact, they have direct connections to all the
major cloud providers too. So
worth checking out Equinix Connect
and seeing what you can do with that
too, but that's not for today session.
So let's spin up some manual
machines first, then we'll kick off the automation.
I'm gonna click new server. Well, I have
some clustered stuff because I have an episode
of clustered tonight. So we'll ignore that.
On demand,
we'll make this bigger so you can kind
of follow along.
And let's see, we're gonna kick off our
first one
in London, just because that's where I am.
We'll do a C3 medium.
We're just gonna use Ubuntu.
I'm gonna use 22.4
because it has this wonderful little lightning bolt,
which means it's quite fast to provision, which
is great.
I don't need to change the name of
the host name. I'm happy for that to
just to be l l d blah blah
blah.
We'll hit deploy.
We all spin up, I'll maybe just do
two for now, although the automation will spin
up more. In fact, manually, I'll just do
one and the automation can spin up the
rest. So
if we come to the automation, there's a
Pulumi directory
and here you're gonna see the cloud config
that I used to automate the entire process
of installing and configuring core DNS,
as well as a Pulumi program, which I'm
using Q for today.
So if you're not familiar with q oh,
I don't have that on this machine.
I have a new machine, which is the
proven fun. My dot fails were not as
complete as I was hoping.
This q lang program
does everything that we need to do to
spin up these servers.
We can use QX port to see what
that looks like in JSON or even YAML.
Actual YAML.
How did I set YAML?
Oh, out fail. Okay.
Dash out
YAML. There we go. This is what it
looks like in YAML. This is what's actually
being run by Pulumi. And we'll go through
that in more detail once we've run through
the actual example.
All I really want to do right now
is just spin this up.
Oh, my token.
All right, let's do this in a nice,
safe and secure fashion.
Now I'll grab a token from another browser.
Too many monitors, I keep losing my mouse.
Okay.
Where did I just paste that?
Nothing is on screen. I think I'm okay.
Okay, so now we should have a password
set and we can run Pulumi up.
What we're gonna see here, let's just go
into our IP block, three devices, one in
The US, EU and Asia. We've got IP
attachments and BGP sessions for all of these
and
we'll hit go.
Right. Hopefully
that just well,
hopefully, that just works.
Invalid authentication token. Okay. So do I not
know how to paste?
Ah, I still got all the YAML on
my buffer.
There we go.
Who'd have thought it was the token that
stumped me or copied and pasted.
Let's let that go. So that should be
better now.
And I'm feeling confident, so I'm gonna go
away from here.
We'll come back to courses,
global reach part three,
create failed.
But only my Tokyo machine.
So that's probably just I've got the Metro
wrong, which I really should have
double checked it, but I'm not gonna worry
about that machine right now. We can still
work it with that. And so I'm gonna
let that spin up just now. We'll pop
back over to Versus Code and yeah. Rio.
Copy and paste is definitely an art that
I should invest in time and learning and
improving,
but not right now because we're busy. Okay.
So
we have one device.
So I've done this back here, but I
actually forgot to reserve myself a global IP.
So we're gonna come over here. We're gonna
go to IPs.
And we're gonna request a new one. You'll
see that my automation already has one, but
we're going to do one more. Now you've
got a couple of options on Equinix.
You've got public IPv4. These are announced or
advertised
only within
metros.
Now, because we want globally
available IP, which means it can be from
anywhere in the world and we're treated accordingly,
we need to go for global.
It's a little bit more expensive. But again,
if you're watching this video and you want
globally distributed service,
then it's probably gonna be worth it.
We just want one, I'm not gonna get
any more. And then I'm gonna submit my
request.
And if I refresh
oh, there we go. I thought they were
the same. They're different.
We now have forty dot twelve as well
as our automation, which got forty dot ten.
Okay. Let's jump back over here. So we've
reserved one.
We have deployed a server.
So I was supposed to be using Chicago,
London, and Sydney. I've been deviated slightly from
that, but you can use whatever metros you
want.
What we need to do now is for
each of the servers where we want to
be able to advertise
BGP address is that we have to go
on and configure a piece of software called
BERT.
BERT is a BGP advertiser.
BERT
BGP.
Here.
So it's just open source software that anyone
can use.
There are other options for advertising BGP addresses,
but I'm quite comfortable with BERT and Equinix
better provide some network helpers, which you'll see
shortly, which actually configure pretty much everything that
we need to do today. So we're gonna
stick with that.
So we are going to
apt update, apt install bert and Python three,
and then we're going to get these network
helpers. So
what do we need? We need the IP
address of our first server,
so we can come back to here.
Oh, no, I clicked on demand.
And this No, I spun up the medium
in London. Yep.
This is my automation.
So we're gonna ignore that for now.
And we are now on a machine, we
can do our apt update.
Moj says awesome Versus Code theme.
Thank you. This is
base 16 dark ocean.
I'm quite partial for the base 16 themes.
There's a whole bunch of varieties, but the
ocean one I find is there. It's quite
nice, especially
looking at code. It's it's really readable,
which is awesome.
Alright. So we've run an apt update. We
now need to install Python
pep get
bert.
Think it's just Python three actually.
Nice. Just takes a moment. These boxes have
pretty good
to interact.
And we have a question from Manuel
who asks, do you know if it's possible
to bring your own IP to Equinix Metal?
You can, actually.
You get a couple of options when it
comes to IPs and BGP with Equinix Metal.
Now I believe you do need to speak
to the support team. Not
all of what I'm about to mention is
available via the portal.
But I know that from the portal you
can
bring your own ASN
and have Equinix advertise IP addresses to it,
which is very, very cool.
It does take
this is one to two business days for
a response.
During my experimentation, it's it's been much faster,
closer to twelve hours.
So you can bring your own ASN and
and
could have a password on it, and you
can advertise to it from Equinix Metal. Very
cool.
And
if you want to bring your own IP
address, you reach out to support, and then
they can hook that up and advertise the
IP address for you once you've confirmed that
it is your IP address to advertise.
So, yes, you 100% can.
Alright. So we now have all of that
bits of software installed, so now we need
to configure our interface.
So we have this cat command here, which
is going to basically add a new IP
address to the loopback device, and we want
this here to be our BGP
global IP.
Why did I get logged out?
Strange.
Okay.
So let's grab that dot 12 IP address
so that we can
configure that as required.
So we'll just copy this, assuming I know
how to copy paste. Right. And I'll drop
this into Versus code here.
Make sure I have the right space there.
And we add this to our interfaces file.
Like so. Oh.
Nope.
Having that error
is okay.
Yes. It is. Good. So we do have
our
our IP address on the loop back to
five.
This
may be an ubuntu twenty two zero four
error. I'm gonna ignore it anyway.
My testing was all done with twenty zero
four, but I decided at the last minute
we should probably use the latest and greatest.
In fact, my automation still uses 2004, so
it's fine. But I'm gonna ignore this message.
This is, I believe, just superficial.
What we really need to see here is
that when we run IP adder, we see
our address. So I'm
happy with that.
And so that I don't commit this,
put this back.
Next, we have to use the Equinix metadata
service. So you can curl and get a
whole bunch of data
from metadata.platformequinix.com
metadata,
type that to JQ,
app install JQ.
And you get all the information about your
actual bare metal device. So you'll see that
you have information on the host name, the
operator of the system, the Metro and facilities,
SSH keys that have access.
You have
the specification for the machines, the type of
CPU, type of drives, the type of NICs.
You've got all the storage information, file system,
everything that you need to know about this
machine,
which some of it you can get just
by working with the
device file system in Linux, but it's all
available over an API.
What's really important for us right now is
that we need access to the BGP neighbors
configuration,
which we haven't enabled yet. So
if I actually run
my
terminals a bit overzealous with a copy there.
If we try and fetch out
the BGP neighbor information, we're not gonna get
anything yet. Now our automation handles as follows,
but the manual approach is that we need
to come into our servers,
click on our manual device, go to BGP,
and
I could say turn it on, but it
does appear to be on.
Did that just happen?
No.
This
was the manual. Yep. London BGP.
Let's just do a quick refresh.
That's weird.
Whenever I'm very unlucky and
there's
some issues.
Ah, there we go. We're gonna turn on
BGP for IPv4.
Someone knocking at my door. We're going to
turn on BGP IV4
for this device. Now this should be pretty
instant.
Yep. There we go. We do a curl
to the metadata service again, using GAQ to
pull it the best that we need to,
and we'll see that here's the ESN number
that we need to advertise to. Here are
the IP addresses that we can do that
with
and yeah, nothing else particularly important there. So
when you're doing this manually, just remember
to come here and turn it on for
IPv4 and IPv6, depending on what you're doing.
Right, next.
So
we need to
run this command,
which is pretty much the same. However, what
we're doing here is getting the gateway
on the management,
getting the gateway on the management interface for
IPv4,
so that we can configure the routes to
go through this.
And then we can configure the gateway IP
for these routes.
So we're gonna copy this,
come to Versus Code
and do this. And this is all handled
by the automation. If you don't like doing
this stuff manually,
it's all good.
Oops.
Oh, I forgot to add the PIN addresses.
This is why automation is important.
So we did this
and this.
And now if we run IP
routes,
you'll see that we can successfully route traffic
to the peers through the public IPv4 address.
We'll undo that, so it'll commit it
and keep going. So now that we have
the roots configured to speak to the peers,
we can
configure and install BERT. Now you don't need
to do any of this manually. The network
helpers available at github.com/packethost/network-helpers
do everything for you. They speak to the
metadata API to pull out all the peer
information to configure BERT. We'll take a look
at the config,
and BERT just starts running via system d
and everything is good.
So you'll see here, it spits that out.
We've got our
static roots configured here.
Oh, cool. I guess you don't need to
add that manually. Well, we're still gonna do
it.
Add the it's got the roots, it's got
the
neighbor and it's got the other neighbor. So
exactly what we need.
We can run a system control
status
bert.
We can see that it's running and I'm
just gonna ignore these letters. These are superficial
as well.
Next, we can run a BERT shell to
confirm that is actually working
and doing what we want.
BERT c.
And we'll
see here that our BGP state is established.
This is good. This is what we want.
We want BERT to be able to successfully
establish and talk to those peers so we
can advertise the address.
And this is not always instantaneous, but if
you need to confirm this even further, you
can go to the admin console. And if
you hit refresh,
yeah, it's not always as instantaneous, but I
updated every six hours. Let's try and force
it be update.
As we should see that this machine has
a learned route.
Yeah. Okay. We're not gonna wait for that.
So that's okay.
Alright. So BGP
is now configured on this device and ready
to go.
Next, what we wanna do is actually run
core DNS.
Now you can do the trace route here
if you want,
but it's just gonna confirm the route that
you take on your local machine or an
Equinix Mineral infrastructure back to that IP address
should be pretty
trivial, I would hope.
So next we're going to install core DNS
on this machine,
which is just a curl from the GitHub
release bayon array and then making it available
on our path,
And then doing that,
we have a question from Moz.
What advantages does BGP offer over direct routing
apart from dynamic routing?
So
BGP is what makes it possible to advertise
one IP address across the entire internet
and
route it to different machines depending on where
the source request comes from.
I don't
I don't believe
it's possible to do this with other technologies.
So what this means is if you think
about traditional networking landscape, you have an IP
address that maps to one machine. Sure. It
can go through some routers and and other
pieces of kit before it gets there, but
it's always one IP address as one machine.
BGP makes it because it works at the
AS level, the autonomous system level, that if
you come into an autonomous system, it can
actually
advertise a prefix or an IP address and
say, I know how to route this traffic
and all of those different autonomous systems can
route differently
depending on where the source traffic is coming
from.
Meaning that if you're in Australia,
then you're gonna be routed to a server
in Australia or as close to Australia as
you can get. Whereas if you're in Europe
or The US, we're gonna route you to
traffic within Europe and The US and as
minimal hops as possible.
We're just in that latency to the first
bite because that's how we build truly scalable
distributed systems on a global scale.
And I don't think it's possible to do
this without BGP. Although, I am happy to
be corrected.
So that is why we would do this
with BGP.
Now the other alternative way to do it,
which is not through a single IP address,
but just through
sharding geographically
at the DNS level,
which is having DNS servers and and edge
locations and having them route the traffic and
return different IP addresses depending on where the
request comes from.
That is not as
I I don't like it as much. There's
definitely more margin for error
and DNS caching and a whole bunch of
other things that you have to deal with,
but it is a route that cloud providers
have used. AWS
and Route 53 definitely offer this as a
feature.
But if you have access to BGP, I
really struggle to see why you just wouldn't
go down the BGP route. So I hope
that helps, Mozz. If you have any follow-up
questions, just drop them in the chat.
And a cool comment there from Manuel. Just
a reminder to everyone here who's not a
network engineer, you want BGP to be established,
not active.
Good tip. Thank you.
Cool.
Let's jump back into this. So we've got
available, but we need to be able to
configure it. And I'm going to do this
rather chaotically.
So let's just oh,
Let's do this first. So we're gonna create
a core DNS directory and we're gonna write
a fake domain to it. Of course, you
should you
should choose real domains, but because of the
way the internet works, I can use whatever
the hell I want and it will just
work because I'm gonna be directly
sending DNS requests to
this BGP address.
So what we're doing here is we're ran
we're using the core DNS file plugin, which
means that you can store all of your
DNS records inside of a file and core
DNS will load them just like bind another
DNS systems to be fair. You can hook
core DNS up to
like databases if you wanted to build it
out that way. But for today,
in fact, in general, like a drill, I
think the file plugin is is pretty spawn,
especially as you can store all these configurations
and get
sync them onto the machines, run CoreDNS,
and then set up system data to do
reloads whenever the files changes and pull new
changes from Git. So,
yeah, good way to do it. Manuel, gotta
go.
Make sure you watch later. I appreciate the
comment.
Thank you very much. I really do appreciate
that. Thank you for joining, and feel free
to comment later when you get around to
watching the rest of the video.
So we are configuring an origin or domain
here for yourfirstdomain.com.
We're setting up some store records. We can
pretty much just ignore these or copy them
from the internet, wherever you want. If you
want to do it a bit more nicely
or properly, feel free. But the only bet
I'm really concerned about right now is that
we have
two records on this domain.
One of them, we're setting up an a
record for www, which is always gonna resolve
to 127001
and an IPv6
local host
QUADI record or 40. I
don't know. I'm not sure what the proper
terminology is there.
However, this is all you need to configure
core DNS to start serving records.
Next, we need a core file, which tells
it to load this configuration. The core file
is the main configuration
for core DNS.
What we're seeing here
is that we're gonna run core DNS support
one five three instead of 53.
And that's because if we try and run
it on 53, system d resolve is gonna
yell at us. So
you don't really want system d resolve to
yell at. You could stop it.
I'll leave that up to you.
What I'm saying here is that I'm gonna
forward all unknown domains
to Google's DNS at eight dot eight dot
eight dot eight. If you wanna use Cloudflare
@ 1 1 1 1 go for it
or your own preferred service, up to you.
Next, we say that any request for your
firstdomain.com
will be loaded from the configuration file that
we wrote earlier.
Next, I've written a systemd service file that
we copy here,
which gives us core DNS handled by systemd.
We can run a daemon reload,
start
core
DNS.
Now, if we've done this correctly,
we should be able to dig
at
one hundred twenty seven thousand and one
dash P one hundred fifty three
and say google.com.
Maybe not.
CoreDNS
running.
It is not.
Alright. Guess we're debugging. So
Oh, the directory doesn't the file doesn't exist.
Twitch, core DNS.
Interesting.
I think there's something wrong with my unit
fail.
Let's fix it.
User Rawkode band. CoreDNS.
Well, this user won't exist.
So these two capabilities allow us to bind
on ports less than one zero two four.
Mean, it does look alright actually.
In fact, let's try running it.
Then core DNS
core fail.
Oh, and it's then dash c.
Nope. Dash conf.
Okay. That worked.
Restart core DNS.
Restart.
I'm not having much luck here.
Alright.
Data
for
DNS.
Yeah. I think it was just the user
pragma instead of my unit file.
So,
I mean, that's best practice, but we haven't
set up a user, so I'm gonna remove
it.
And we do have it working
and we do a dig, we get it
forward and on and we get an IP
address. So this looks good at the moment,
but we'll confirm that. Let me jump into
the comment.
So we've got one from RIO.
BGP can be fun. I remember someone able
to draw a nine cat on the right
dashboard that were in traffic different over time.
That's scary.
I'd love to see that. That sounds awesome.
Very cool.
Oh, you were trying to debug my problem
with me, chmod plus x. No, I I
think the permission was okay. The the script
that we used to install that do a
chmod anyway,
but I think it was just the user.
And the question from us, does core
DNS support caching?
It does. It has a whole bunch of
plugins actually.
So if you come here to core dns.
Go to plugins.
Well, we got here, we've got ACLs. If
you wanna control who can request records from
particular domains, if you wanna load bind files,
if you wanna work with Azure,
then there's a cache one here. So if
we click on that,
this will cache records.
Yeah. Well, the configuration or how long to
cache it for, etcetera.
Those plugins for
yeah. There's lots of stuff here. DNSSEC.
Really, I should start experimenting with that. I
keep being entered to that in my domains,
but I just haven't got around to it
yet.
STD support,
GeoIP,
if you want to go down that route,
gRPC,
headers. Yeah. There there's
there's just the support to plug ins and
then there's the external plug ins as well.
So, yeah, there's there's lots of cool stuff
here. So
core DNS is great.
So let's,
we tested Google and we've seen that that
was forwarded on
correctly, which is great.
Let's try your firstdomain.com
and we only set up www as IPv4.
So if we do that, we do get
this here, although we still, you know, we
have fake authority section here.
Don't do that in your own configuration.
This is just a demo.
But we have the
here. So this
is working. We have a DNS server that
works.
I can use our BGP address now instead
of doing 127.
So I can come here
and
as you can see, I've tested this on
my own machine previously.
Our BGP address, it's similar,
but not, I know it's dot 12 and
there's something in the middle. So let's take
a look at what that is.
BGP.
Nope. BGP.
Oh, it's not completely different IP address this
time.
We're not completely different.
Okay. So we do dig at
port
and we hit it and we get one
two seven back. So this is from my
local machine. This is not with an Equinix
metal. And if we actually do a trace
route
to the type,
I've obviously got copy
on
highlight on this new machine.
And if we run the trace route, we're
gonna have to go through
this is a five g router that I'm
on in my office, believe it or not.
So we're gonna see a whole bunch of
failed hops. And I really should have set
the retry on failed hops to one, but
never gonna have to wait for five stars
on each.
But we'll see the route that this takes
to the Equinix better infrastructure, and, course, we
could run this from another machine and see
that routed slightly differently
if we had more than one server,
which is where the automation comes in. So
we can take a look at how you
take this manual process that I've done,
repeat that using Pulumi. You could also do
this with TerraForm and
deploy to as many regions as you want.
So we'll take a look at how I'm
using CURE to template out all this YAML
and hopefully give you a good idea of
how you can do something similar for yourself.
I'm going to drink this coffee and hope
that the stars disappears.
More stars.
So people
that aren't aware,
the stars on a tracer are in fact,
here's do you know how how
a tracer works?
What it does is that every time you
make a request to something on the Internet,
it goes through something called a hop. Every
device that you go past in order to
get to your target device is one hop.
As those hop respond to an ICMP ping,
then we will get information like we see
here.
If they did not respond to an ICMP
ping,
it will try it again. And I thought
it was five times, but it's three stars,
so it tries three times and the star
just means that it didn't respond.
So what we'll see here is that when
we do get information,
things are much faster, which is why a
trace route can be a little bit slow
at times.
And the way
that it works out the devices is also
kinda
crude, but really, really cool.
When you set up any request on your
machine to the Internet, you set a time
to live,
which means that every time you go through
another device, it will decrement that and when
basically, how many hops you're willing to accept
to reach or be routed to another device.
And what Tracer actually does is set that
time to left to one so that it
gets terminated at the first device and then
gets the ping back and then sets it
to two and then sets it to three
and then sets it to four until you
get to the device that correctly identifies as
the device that you're trying to reach.
Very crude, but it works really, really well.
And Rio is talking about MTR as well
in the comment. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely very cool
too. I don't believe I have MTR available.
Okay.
So there's not really much more to show
from the manual perspective.
We deployed a metal device. We hooked up
BGP via IPv4.
We deployed a configured BERT, and then
we configured core DNS using the fail plugin
to
specify the domains that we wanted to respond
for.
We have made requests from the machine itself
and from my own machine using the BGP
address.
We could see the trace route
does get there eventually. I'm not actually sure.
This must be a
BGP thing. I never actually considered it before.
This is not IP address multiple times just
means that
we're being routed through. That's just the Equinix
Mail infrastructure at that point.
Now let's see the automation.
So if we pop over here oh, okay.
Oh, I think that failed because of that
one device that I couldn't spin up,
which is a
it's just a wrong
metro.
Oh, there aren't any
servers. Alright. Okay. Let's just remove that one.
So I'm gonna modify
the automation and run it again, and then
we'll run through the automation as well.
Now let's just remove
that.
Those devices, the other two devices are already
spun up, that should be nice and fast
and we're not gonna have to wait too
long. Yeah. So now we're just doing attachments
and BGP sessions.
Okay. So this is a Pulumi YAML program.
However, I have used a custom
compiler,
which we can do with Pulumi, but I
just say instead of
we're gonna provide you YAML straight up. Instead,
we have to do some sort of compilation
step to get the YAML back out
or JSON. And for that, we're going to
use Q export
as I ran on the command line earlier.
Q actually allows us to take Q and
spit out a whole bunch of formats. We
can do JSON.
I'm sure there's more, but I'm not gonna
risk it and try and see if TOML
is supported.
So,
yeah, that's the PLUIvy program written in Q.
We're using Q because that allows us to
encapsulate
YAML into, like, definitions, which can be reused
over and over again, and we'll go through
that in just a moment. So the first
thing I need to do is set some
variables.
Now we can specify here
a project ID.
I do include the code and the repository
if you want to create the project by
yourself.
However, waiting for the approval for the global
BGP to be enabled on that, again, can
take a little bit of time. So that's
if you want to go down that route,
but you don't have to.
Next, we're using Cloud Config and here we're
just saying that we have these parts.
I've not added all the parts. In fact,
Skeptr here, I've just not added them to
the queue. I'll update that after this session.
But the first thing we want to do
is Bootstrap.
There's also setup bird and core DNS.
So these are just shell scripts that do
everything that we did
manually by SSH,
but in an automated fashion. So you'll see
here we installed JQ. We're looking and waiting,
so we're on a while loop or an
until loop until that BGP information comes through
the metadata API. So if it's not there
at first, it usually just takes a few
few seconds.
And we also write custom data to some
JSON as well. The custom data endpoint is
how we pass in the BGP address to
the machine because that is not available over
the metadata API.
Next, we set a BERT exact same commands,
and we pull the global IP address from
the custom data using JQ to get a
single value.
We configure the look back device. We get
the gateway IP address.
For each of those peers, we add a
root,
and then we install BERT and use network
helpers.
So the exact same commands almost verbatim that
we ran via SSH.
Next, have the core DNS configuration. Again,
it's pretty much the same. We download the
binary and we stuck it into a directory.
We write some configuration
and
we set up the system to the unit
file,
remove the user,
and that'll just work.
Well, actually, that's probably not working and I'm
gonna have to manually go into those two
devices, remove that user and restart it, but
maybe open.
If we go back to the queue, we
have a request for the global IP. So
we're not manually looking for a BGP address
this time. We are using the Pulumi provider.
It's saying give me a reserved IP block.
It has to be a global IPv4.
We only need one address, so slash 30
two.
Then we're using something called a core DNS
device,
which is a definition in queue, which is
how we get modularity slash reuse,
and we configure that definition. So we're saying
here,
tweak the name of the device to be
EU or US
and deploy it to different metros. This is
Dallas in The US, and this is Amsterdam
in The EU.
And we're just pulling out the resources from
that definition and to the top level plan.
The queue definition itself has the configuration values
at the top where we specify the type
that we expect, but nothing else.
Then we can define the resources for this
definition. So we have a device.
Here's supports interpolation.
So we're saying pull in the name from
here.
We spin up an Equinix model device. We're
using c three smalls with a older version
of Ubuntu
passing the project ID, the Metro,
the user data as our cloud config, but
it's the rendered version.
So we're concatenating all those different scripts together
as a multi part cloud configuration file.
And we pass in our global IP so
that we have access to that within the
cloud and its system, which is important because
we need it.
Once that device spins up, we do the
IP attachment. So we tell EquinixMetal that this
device can advertise this IP address and we
create the session. So we just say, hey,
we want to enable IPv four on this
device.
The same way we did on the interface
with the little tick box that had me
confused for half a minute.
That's it.
The Pulumi app gives us the devices.
We come to the console.
We'll see we have one machine here in
Dallas.
So let's jump onto there.
Get my finger.
Let's see if Bart is happy first.
Oh,
It's not happy,
which means something went wrong.
This is the output from my user data
script. You can see it's sleeping, sleeping, sleeping,
waiting for that BGP information. It has the
BGP information. Oh, that's why.
Because
I am silly. I even mentioned this as
I did it, but
we need to
do all the scripts. So we have just
run these ones manually that are needed. So
there's setup bert
and there is three
core DNS.
So let's just run the script
and we'll grab this script.
I think what we'll do is I'm gonna
jump onto the other machine and start pasting
these scripts in as well.
That's the core DNS one.
Woah.
I definitely angered that.
And the other server is here.
Alright. What did I copy incorrectly from here?
Oh yeah, because this is a markdown fail.
No, wait, it shouldn't be.
Oh, I have just copied this wrong.
That should be that.
There's no more of those, is there?
No, good. Okay, so that should fix the
first device.
Okay. We'll do that one by one.
Do we have core DNS?
Yeah.
Do we have
our config?
Yes.
So it's just the unit fail.
That looks alright.
Yeah.
Clearly I'm just struggling with copy and paste
again. So
let's do a restart core DNS,
status,
core
That's probably that unit fail
system
core DNS.
Of
course. Thank you, Rio.
Rio noticed that main pad will need to
be escaped.
Good call.
Because it's saying include in it, it's not
saying here.
And I can just copy it.
Alright.
Save
daemon
reload.
Restart
core DNS
status.
What? Oh, the origin hasn't been escaped either.
Ran into this. I do do some testing.
Yeah. This here is gonna be wrong. So
let's just fix that.
This is just stuff that works when it
runs through cloud in it, but not when
I'm pasting it into the terminal because the
interpretation works differently.
That's what was missing.
That actually looks alright.
Run it manually.
Okay.
Restart
core DNS.
Hopefully,
it must be running low because the port
was taken.
No.
Maybe it was restarting when it did it.
Oh, wait. Cannot serve DNS one type three
is already defined.
Computers.
And that should be the fail.
First demand.
That looks fine. Core fails probably where there's
a bug.
Oh,
because by automation, append
to the file.
Right.
Things work when I'm not being very, very
stupid.
So let's restart core DNS.
The status on this is 100% gonna be
okay now. Good.
We wanted to be able to run this
on the second machine. So we're gonna quickly
run through the set up BERT again.
I believe this just worked. There was no
errors here.
And then we'll be careful with this one.
I'm just gonna copy the whole thing,
write it to file and then execute it,
and then we don't have to worry about
the interpolation.
So Mozz asked,
is it a good idea to replace bind
with core DNS?
Depends on your use case.
I find it easier to work with core
DNS.
I like its plugins.
It's what Kubernetes uses, so I feel like
my knowledge is a bit more transferable there
than my you know, I have a lot
of Bain knowledge from the early two thousands,
late '2 thousands,
but
I think it's consolidating on more modern technology.
Even though Bain still works, it's still great.
It probably still powers most of the Internet,
I just I'm leaning more towards core team
these days.
Alright.
So let's just paste this and run this.
Oh, wait. Let's see my local.
I'm
just doing everything wrong. 40 c. Yeah. This
is a different machine.
Oh, that's my London machine.
Computers
are kicking my ass.
Alright. So fem a Sh,
what is there?
So I got exited from this
for reasons.
No. Cool.
Let's make sure there's no duplication in our
core DNS file, in our core file.
Good.
The daemon
reload. We're gonna get there
and the core DNS.
If we run a status,
it's happy. Now
where we are is we have one machine
running in Dallas, One machine running in Amsterdam,
both
handling a DNS for your first domain dot
com
via a single
global IPv
four
BGP advertised address.
Okay.
Let's grab that address.
And it's the 40 Dot 10.
And we're on my local machine.
Do a dig at -p153google.com.
Oh, on port.
So that uses the forward plugin and pushes
me on.
Your firstdomain.com
should be empty, but if we add w
w w,
we get the correct record.
So this is cool.
But where am I going? Well, let's do
a traceroute.
What's the parameters on that to do
field ping one.
Let's
try that.
Yeah. Cool. This won't take too long.
But hopefully, we see this
go through some sort of European Amsterdam
data center into Equinix Medal. We can use
like we did on part one of this
course, there's some web interfaces,
which will give you a kind of better
this traceroute actually isn't very useful whatsoever.
So let's do traceroute
web.
Maybe.
There we go.
So
we're not really getting any reverse DNS information.
Normally,
it would show you. However,
not a big deal.
What we can see here from Frankfurt is
we go through some sort of forty five
eleven network from Amsterdam is 1851,
from London is 1851,
is 19832.
Well, we don't have reverse
DNS lookup to show us, like, maybe this
comes through Amsterdam Center, Dallas Center, parts of
The US, etcetera.
And the IP addresses are all different. The
routes are being different. They are being propagated
through the Equinix metal network.
Good.
What's BGP Looking Glass do? Is that anything
cool? I don't know.
There's normally a more visual one, but it
doesn't really matter.
So that's it for today.
This repository, I'll push these updates that we've
fixed during today's session.
I hope this gives people a good understanding
of,
you know, cementing and building on the knowledge
that hopefully we transferred to part one about
what BGP is and why it's important to
a more concrete use case where you can
run your own DNS servers. Now you probably
you may, but, you know, you may not
do this with your own public domains, but
if you have certain security characteristics or constraints
in your organization,
running your own private DNS servers
using BGP could be a a good way
to navigate and handle some of those traffic.
And we're gonna build on this yet again
with the next session in this course. Let
me pop back over to face mode.
So
on the next session,
we are actually going to take this up
gear
and okay. What else is really good at
the edge in multiple locations?
We're gonna take a look at applying
a functions as a service or serverless framework
and multiple metros across Equinix Metal so that
you can have functions at the edge. Cloudflare
Workers are amazing.
They have this wonderful technology where you can
write code that gets run-in over 250 locations
as close to your customers as possible.
This is a really compelling argument for building
globally distributed applications.
So we're gonna take a look at how
we can do that using EquinixMail and some
open source software. So we will deploy functions
at the edge. We'll use a web
system
scraper to
fire off bunch of requests from a bunch
of different locations. And what we wanna be
able to see and what we will see
is that no matter where we send requests,
we're gonna see
very, very good first of
time to first bite and minimal latency across
all of those edge locations.
But until then, I will see you all
soon. If you have any questions, feel free
to leave some in the comments below. We'll
be back with the third part of this
course in two weeks. I'm at a conference
in London next week, but I will be
back the week after where we'll do and
build something fun. So until then, have a
great day. I'll see you all soon. Bye.